[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and just as Star
Wars is about to wrap up with episode 9
the rise of Skywalker it seems like
Disney have big plans for the future of
the franchise this morning we got the
news from The Hollywood Reporter that
Kevin Feige will officially be
developing a Star Wars film at Disney
the marbled president is arguably one of
the most successful movie producers if
not the most successful movie producer
of all time and I think everyone is well
aware of how much the MCU has raked in
with him at the helm Star Wars however
has went from one of the biggest movie
sagas to slowly having dwindling
interest from the fanbase with the last
Jedi Durrell in a lot of people's love
for the series the blame is often put at
Kathleen Kennedy's feet who is pretty
much seen as the one who is ruined the
franchise in some fans eyes and whilst
is Lee have stated that buggy will be
working alongside Kennedy as part of
this a personally thing that this is a
lot of PR talk this seems like a
desperate move by Disney in my opinion
and to call someone across to steer the
ship it just seems like an act that
really shows that they don't have much
faith in the heads that are currently
behind the series though there have
always been rumors that Kathleen Kennedy
will be removed from Star Wars I
personally think that Kevin Feige has
been brought in more as a consultant to
help guide the franchise going forward
and to also create his own branching
universe should kennedy's projects fail
now this is interesting because one of
the main points from the spider-man
Disney Sony deal collapse was that
Fergie did not have enough time to
dedicate to the Sony property and the
fact that he is working on Star Wars now
as well could have been a huge deciding
factor Disney Co chairman alan horne
told The Hollywood Reporter we are
excited about the projects Kathy and the
Lucasfilm team are working on not only
in terms of Star Wars but also Indiana
Jones and reaching into other parts of
the company including children of blood
and bone with Emma watts and Foxx with
the close of the Skywalker saga Kathy is
pursuing a new era in Star Wars
storytelling and knowing what a die-hard
fan
it made sense for these two
extraordinary producers to work on a
Star Wars film together this is
interesting because it seems like Disney
have lost a lot of faith in Kennedy but
don't want to oust her just yet before
the final chapter in here trilogy so
they are making it seem like everything
is amicable whether the rise of
Skywalker's as well I think will be the
deciding factor though it probably will
kill at the box office in addition to
this Feige already has the internet
speculating by stating that he has an
unnamed major actor in mind for a
specific role in his upcoming Star Wars
film Disney at the moment are going all
out with Star Wars and though they did
say that they were coming down with the
release of films I think this
announcement proves otherwise in
addition to the foggy movie there is
also a separate Rian Johnson trilogy in
the works as well as another one with
the Game of Thrones showrunners behind
it so yeah it's pretty much doomed if
Feige doesn't get involved now obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on this
and if you think it's a PR stunt or do
you think that we should take the studio
at their word should Disney pump the
brakes on Star Wars and do you agree
that this is an act of desperation
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of the news that there's some big stars
returning for Jurassic world 3 I'll
leave that linked at the end and if you
want to come check to me about movies TV
shows games and comic books
then make sure you follow me on twitter
at definition whitey it's the best way
to get in touch with me and it's the
perfect place to suggest new videos and
topics so hopefully I see you over there
after this I also just wanna let you
know that we're currently giving away a
free copy of spider-man far from home on
blu-ray and all you have to do to be in
with the chance of winning is to like
this video make sure that you subscribe
to the channel and leave your thoughts
on the star wars situation in the
comments section below the winner will
be chosen at random on October the 15th
and the blu-ray will be shipped out from
the end whoever gets the prize so best
of luck to everyone who takes part this
is the channel for people who are mad
into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definitionally you've been the
best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]